Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Now
I'm a cybernetic organism living this year.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike in the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him,
I said,
dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers.
And he said,
I've been doing Peloton five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin.
But it really peaked my curiosity,
ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You know if worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to a
studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand and in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have
their favorite instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the real time leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
You might say man accessories,
wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes.
And those are in the accessory category.
So there's $100 off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including the shoes that you all want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim.
Okay.
This episode is sponsored by Sotheby's and Sotheby's wine,
which offers a selection of the world's best wines for every pallet and
occasion.
Many of you know I do like my wine.
I do love wine.
Must be the Malbec from Argentina when I was down there,
or maybe it's a Zinfandel from California,
but I like it all.
I like lots and lots of wine.
Southerby's,
as many of you may know,
is a global auctioneer.
They auction off many,
many,
many different types of things.
There are also a retailer of fine wine with locations in New York,
London,
and Hong Kong.
The recently created an online store where you can buy wine directly.
You might think,
well that's for millionaires and billionaires.
I don't go to auction houses,
but the wines that they sell range from $14 per bottle all the way up to 25,000
let's say Sotheby's allows you to sort it by region,
great producer or you can search for a particular bottle or by your budget,
which is probably where I would go if you're gifting wine southeast,
suggest champagne,
red Bordeaux,
burgundy or Californian wines.
And if you want my opinion,
I would say,
you know,
tries Zinfandel.
If you haven't tried to Zinfandel from California,
but in any case,
just one restriction at this time a Sotheby's can only ship to New York,
California,
DC,
New Hampshire and Idaho.
So I'll say that one more time and I'll put it a different way.
If you are in or shipping to New York,
California,
DC,
New Hampshire or Idaho,
check it out because that's where the wine can currently be shipped.
So visit Sotheby's wine.com that's s o t h e B y s Sotheby's wine.com and use
the Promo Code Tim Tim to get 10% off of your first order.
Again,
that's Sotheby's wine.com and use Promo Code Tim for 10% off of your delicious.
Wow.
Check it out.
Yeah.
Why?
Hello there and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
This is Tim Ferriss and it is typically my job to share the habits and routines
of world class performers of all different types as well as try to spot the
patterns amongst them and talk that this episode is a rare exception to the rule
and unlike my usual long form interviews,
this is a drunk dialing Q and a with you guys,
my listeners.
So what does that mean?
I've done this a few times in the past,
including for the celebration of the hundredth episode of this podcast.
We're at more than 300 now,
so it's been awhile and here's how it works.
In preparation for this episode.
I went on the social media and a point people to a Google form where they could
input their phone numbers and so on and those people,
our listeners wanted to receive a call from me.
Then I said,
hey,
from this time to this time I'm going to be making phone calls and I started
drinking in dialing,
answering your questions and getting a little frisky along the way.
Tequila,
we'll do that and we covered a lot in this episode.
I cover all sorts of things including how Jocko Willink has made me more
disciplined.
My thoughts on sex as a doorway to higher perception.
That was not a topic I expect to get into.
And uh,
you name it,
we cover it.
I talk about a past addiction to stimulants that I've had and how I've weaned
myself off of said stimulants or at least prioritized abstinence from
stimulants.
How I determine if a project is working or not put another way,
how do I decide when I should persevere,
were quit a project,
stop something and move on.
And after all,
the fastest way to complete something is to leave it undone forever.
Uh,
so that is one topic that we dig into,
how I think about teaching and much,
much more.
So I'll leave it at that.
Without further ado,
please enjoy this Tequila fueled Q and a with you guys and thanks for being
game.
Here we go.
Hello.
Hi,
is this Brendan?
Is this Tim Ferris?
It is Tim Ferriss.
Good evening.
Why?
Oh my goodness.
Oh Man.
Where am I?
Where am I finding,
I'm doing great.
Where are you right now?
Probably about three hours north of weight I assume you want,
I'm in Dallas,
Texas.
Oh,
nice.
It's fine.
Towns.
I find town Dallas.
Okay.
Yeah.
Have you been through here march or no,
I've been here.
I've been here,
I've been there.
That's the alcohol talking.
Excuse me.
I have been there a handful of times as well as fort worth,
but I've always spent more time in the Austin area.
Uh,
so,
uh,
understandably so.
It's,
it's,
it's a fine,
fine community.
I was just actually down there yesterday.
Very nice.
For south by or what were you down here for him?
I just went down to go to the academy and then to get a little workout in and
synchronize synchronistically enough.
You really set podcasts with Abi this yesterday.
I listen to that on the tie back.
It's a great gym.
So I tell you what,
I've got a bunch of phone calls to make a bunch of booze to drink.
So how can I,
how can I attempt to help?
What type of questions might I
take a stab at?
Good,
good,
good question because I know you collect them.
So I actually took a little bit of time once I saw that sweets,
I was expecting this phone call.
So,
um,
an easy one that I just wanted to ask because it's been one of the biggest
things that you felt me with of all the people that you've introduced me to.
So all your worth is juggle willing.
So I wanted to know just from your perspective,
has having him around in your life made you more discipline?
That is a fine question.
Yes.
So having Jocko
in my life,
which I will say is also virtual,
even though I know Jocko very well,
I just spoke to him yesterday on the phone.
But simply knowing that Jocko exists in the universe,
uh,
makes me feel like I have a very benevolent yet strict a guardian angel who will
most certainly give me an occasional pat on the back,
but more often a kick in the ass to actually do it.
What needs being done?
So Jocko I think exemplifies,
for me at least
the importance of deciding to embody a given attribute as a means to developing
that attribute.
So of course Jocko is well known for saying if you want to be tougher,
be tougher,
simply meeting in that context that if you want to be tougher,
it's not a six month plan,
it's not a two year plan,
it's not a progression.
It is.
Do I choose the stairs instead of the elevator when I get up from this table and
I need to go to another floor?
And it can be a small decision,
it can be a big decision,
but you want to immediately start making decisions that reflect the
characteristic you want to develop.
And that that I think is very powerful and also quite frankly,
the simplicity of Jockos approach to many things including physical fitness and
training it which
after listening to your podcast and
stuff we put together.
But like,
you know,
difficult to execute with correct form and like advocate in that public cadence
and everything like that is principal simple from
extreme ownership.
You know,
it's like just don't overcomplicate things.
And I think that in a way simplicity is like expression on elegance.
It is absolutely.
And also the fact that Jocko does not accept excuses in his own life and
certainly doesn't accept them from other people.
And as one example,
he,
if he's traveling and you know this from having read the last book,
but if he's traveling and he wants to do pull ups and he doesn't have any pullup
bar nearby,
let's say in a hotel,
he will take a towel,
go to the parking garage,
find something from which you can hang using the towel,
like throw it over a bar or something like that and he'll pull up.
Exactly right.
So,
uh,
in those,
for those of you who don't have the context,
Jocko Willink is a legendary former or I should say retired navy seal commander.
He was in charge of one point of all west coast training for navy seal teams,
which are certainly realistic,
hyper realistic.
One might even call psychotic.
He's a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu and can do last I heard 67 strict pull
ups at a body weight of somewhere between two 15 and two 30.
So the guy is an absolute animal,
he's a monster.
And then I can just a mental monster too,
you know
like the different kind of like inspiration and motivation.
It's like a really like examine and look at yourself and like just be realistic
about how many hours you're willing to put in the day.
A lot of people,
if they,
if they could be night owls and they might stay up til four 30 or you know,
so long as you're putting in work between midnight and 6:00 AM at some point
you're still ahead of most people are before you go to sleep or right when you
get up.
Yup.
So if you want to also see the most hilarious a Twitter Q and A's imaginable,
you can follow Jocko Jocko Willink on Twitter.
Okay.
So enough enough Jocko Jocko.
But
yeah,
I know,
I know.
I didn't want to just call again,
but we've been one of the most,
he's in one of the most influential of all the people you've introduced me to
this.
I see.
I just wanted to wrap up with one thing.
Do you remember,
Oh,
you know what I should say,
I apologize.
Just to interrupt.
I will say if people want to get to know Jocko,
the very first interview he ever did publicly,
it was on my podcast.
So you can just go to tim.blog forward slash Jocko.
And
what's the video?
He came home and saw that just today or two days ago.
It's about the clock running out.
Like people should check out his youtube channel.
It's like two,
two and a half minutes or something.
It's amazing.
Yup.
So I've helped to create or I'd rather just really unleashed on the internet and
a monster notice Jocko Willink.
So enjoy.
Okay.
So what's next?
Um,
one quick one.
What do you,
are you drinking all day?
What do you having?
I am drinking Casa that are going is sipping Tequila in this case 100% Butoh
Algavia made and um,
it's,
it's from some McGill Dan day and it is Nikila Blanco.
It's nice stuff.
Cool.
The last question is I like I see we met,
did you,
do you remember that it was a club.
I got this la you did your,
you did like a like,
like basically like a meet and greet.
I remember cross campus.
Yeah,
so I flew up from Dallas actually that time and got to kind of interact with you
a little bit.
I think I met you in this hallway space.
It was by the way in the back of the room behind the main stage kind of on my
way to get a drink and go to the bathroom.
I think I actually,
you kind of stepped in front of a few people and I met you there if I remember
correctly.
Yeah,
I remember the very beginning of it like yeah please.
Like I'm not taking startup pitches right now.
And it was just like as soon as there was a break for coffee,
like you have to go for the coffee and it was just like swarmed with people
asking him about like,
oh when you check this product
it looks like all these people and they were just swimming you.
I got a second to talk to you and I was just like,
I just want to say thank you and I still do want to say thank you today man.
I'm really grateful for everything that you've really led me towards in my life.
Like I basically,
you're like one of the best decision making or content filtering algorithms that
I was ever found because if you vet something,
it's already like so much of the legwork is done and I just trust you on like,
you know,
you're driven for research and helping people.
So
thank you Brandon
hopes and never betray that trust.
I mean,
I do,
I really work hard to not succumb to the temptation to loosen that filter.
Uh,
it's,
it's very,
it can be very challenging.
It's very expensive.
Uh,
but I,
uh,
I know how valuable that is to me.
I have friends who act as filters,
certainly,
and it's,
it's,
it's largely thanks to the value that I've derived from them that I want to try
to serve the same function for people in the wider world,
uh,
that I can hopefully try a thousand things and a lot of bullshit and distill the
two or three that are actually worth a second look.
Uh,
anyway,
well,
thank you so much for calling.
I don't,
I don't want to be respectful of everybody else on your list to talk to you for.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure man.
Any,
any requests for the podcast types of people,
specific people or anything else?
What I want to do after like having been introduced to your work in 2011 um,
I was basically,
I grew up in hospitality and I was a chef from many of the last years and was
just unable to kind of sustain like a healthy lifestyle and like,
you know,
there's no such thing as work life balance if you're like a true chef,
cooking real food,
like in a high pressure,
fine dining environment,
like what everything's made from scratch.
Like it's just,
I know you know that from your research and you know,
going through with the four hour chef,
but like it's a pretty widespread like unknown issue in the states right now
that there's not enough skilled labor in kitchens.
I'm not just kitchens or restaurants in general.
So I don't know.
I mean I want to make a difference in that industry on like a bigger scale.
So,
I mean I want to put together like a website and like have like a ton of ideas
in the realm of trying to help people in that specific genre of,
well I should say niche of like the workplace,
but because I have so much experience,
like I grew up in a restaurant when my mom was like,
you know,
uh,
raising me,
I was basically,
I was in a restaurant.
So,
and then coming down to Dallas,
Texas,
like there's just so much opportunity down here and I got a real sense for the
labor market and kind of did some research and it's not just the Dallas living
it.
I'm sure you know any body listening in any city right now that has anything to
do with restaurants can attest to the fact that do,
it helps harder to find than ever because the market's oversaturated and it's
easier to get loans to open restaurants and whatever the case may be,
macro economically.
But I just want to make a difference.
So if anybody's interested,
they can catch me on Twitter at [inaudible] 27 or however you want to.
I just want to start a bigger conversation around this and put out content to
help people and restaurants.
So,
all right,
you're here.
Well,
good luck and I'll see you on the internet maybe in Texas.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
I thought the Dallas just hit me up and I'll probably show you some,
some parts of the city that you,
I didn't see.
All right man.
Well I will,
I'll see you on the road and take it easy.
Bye.
Hello?
Uh,
hi.
Is this Diana?
Yeah,
this is a [inaudible].
I was hoping I would get the pronunciation right.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Good evening.
How are you?
Hello?
Hello.
I can't believe I made it.
You made it.
You were the second person to fill the form out.
So you were very,
very fast on the draw and awesome.
Thank you for coming.
My pleasure.
What question or questions can I ask a question to tackle for?
Well,
I have a,
I have a couple I want you to choose.
Do you want to ECU question?
Do you want a hard question?
I want whichever question that you'd be most disappointed not to have asked.
Okay.
So,
um,
my biggest interest right now is what states have higher perception.
Can we call TV through training?
All right.
And what's coming to me is sex because sex seems to be a doorway in some
cultures or some philosophies.
Like I'm thinking Tantra,
I'm thinking towers them.
I'm thinking Kama Sutra and you know,
so I've,
I've heard this,
I'm,
and I'm trying to put them together,
for example,
um,
abstaining from sex,
like you were talking to Jack Cornfield's or withholding orgasm as a training or
multiple partners and have relationships.
And that's how a lot of sick guys,
so way off learning how to deal with your internal stuff.
So I'm curious to know,
what is your experience,
if I can assume that you've experimented with all of this and what do you think?
Is that a doorway to higher perception,
either of these techniques or all of them or what,
what do you think?
Yeah,
big question.
Let me
try to take a stab at it.
So there are many different components to that question.
I would say that,
uh,
in general,
my experience has been whenever you take an act or a daily habit,
let's just say such as eating and you make previously automatic or subconscious
decisions conscious that you can very deliberately change perception and that
that can lead many interesting places that could take the form of,
and I will get to sex,
but that could take the form of intermittent fasting or fasting,
in which case you notice how much of your day is structured around three
scheduled meals,
whether or not you are hungry and that brings to you a new appreciation of your
automatic behaviors that may or may not be justified.
And secondly gives you a greater appreciation for,
in this case,
the thing he may abstain from for a certain period of time,
which is food and sex is very similar.
Uh,
I do think that,
uh,
and I don't know if this is physiological or psychological,
but I have engaged in a number of different practices and schools of training
where
the accepted best practices involve abstaining from sex.
And furthermore,
abstaining from orgasm or ejaculation for a period of time,
whether that is two weeks or four weeks or a longer period of time.
And when you remove any compulsive behavior,
and I will just go out on a limb and say,
I think that masturbation for men in particular can be a compulsive,
uh,
behavior and tool for procrastination,
to,
to put,
to put it mildly.
Women may be also,
but I think particularly men and that when you remove that as an option and you
have a,
for instance,
a trip plan where you're going to be engaging in some type of physical practice
or exposure to psychedelics or whatever it might be.
And it is clearly,
it has been clearly expressed to you that your,
your gains will be three x four x five x greater if you abstain from this
behavior,
uh,
that is the petri dish,
the,
the period of abstinence that can allow you to observe how you react to that.
Right.
And,
uh,
observing the impulses and the resistance that surfaces,
I think is really valuable.
Uh,
so I do think that whether or not there is some type of physiological basis to
the regeneration of re circulation of chief,
for instance,
which may or may not be the case.
Right.
I'm very,
very skeptical of a lot of this new age.
We will stuff,
even though I've read,
you know,
the,
I believe it's the multiorgasmic man Mantak Chia,
and I've looked at those exercises and I have experimented with a withholding or
postponing ejaculation in some cases where you can use SAPE or have a partner
use fingers in the premium with pressure to prevent that from happening
mechanically,
which I don't actually think,
and this is subject great debate,
but it doesn't strike me as the healthiest approach.
I mean,
she was like sticking a potato and an exhaust pipe or something.
It doesn't seem structurally.
Yeah,
it does.
It all.
Yeah,
exactly.
And also,
it doesn't seem just very structurally prudent to do,
uh,
that if you,
for instance,
as a male,
uh,
and I mean male and female physiology are of course very,
very different,
uh,
when it,
when it comes to sex in multiple respects.
But as a man,
uh,
certainly learning to develop a sensitivity to when you're about to ejaculate
and focusing on say,
breathing patterns or visualization that let's do two allows you to extend the
duration of intercourse or think is tremendously valuable.
And it also transcends the bedroom.
I think it goes other places.
Right?
Uh,
that's my question actually related to creativity and to see east there's a
correlation between,
again,
I get the discipline and the,
the,
the interrupts in north,
the habitual patterns.
I understand that,
but I don't know,
I haven't experienced personally do,
does that translate into,
okay then I'm more able to perceive nature or be more creative in my writing or
be more aware of more present because I'm not giving my energy into this?
Well,
no,
actually yeah,
I think it's energy.
I think it's also cognitive load.
Uh,
the,
the degree to which any given activity is an interrupt of thought.
And when you remove something like that for a period of time,
it ceases to be static in the mind and therefore your signal to noise ratio
improves.
And ostensibly you should be able to,
in my experience is that you can,
you can operate at a higher level when it comes to almost all of your other
activities,
which is why very often when I'm abstaining from one thing,
for instance,
sex,
I'll also abstained from alcohol.
I will also abstain from caffeine and I tend to layer those things on top of one
another.
Yeah.
How,
how long have you been able to abstain from all that stimulus that distract you
from a certain,
yeah,
I did it earlier this year for almost eight weeks,
uh,
which is,
which is a long,
which is a long time for me.
Uh,
me
mom did.
I'm like,
dude,
can I do this?
Yeah,
it's a long time.
But I found it very,
very worthwhile and it proved to me also that I could do it.
And if you will,
and wonder whether or not you are addicted some to something,
you should try to go without it and you will,
you will potentially suffer physical and psychological withdrawal symptoms and
your willingness to contend with that.
We'll give you a very accurate read of how addicted you are to whatever it is
you're abstaining from,
whether it's a thought,
whether it's,
let me just,
yeah.
And it's more about commitment.
It's like I been there,
it was the undulation shower Sunday.
Yeah.
You know,
waking up early in the morning and man,
it's hard to commit to it every single day.
It's more the discipline aspect that is exciting to make us my,
I know that if I tackle that then I'll get a way bigger picture.
Yeah.
Well when I say addiction,
I'm not talking about addiction to nicotine or caffeine necessarily.
I'm also talking about compulsive thought patterns.
Uh,
so for,
so for instance,
I mean if,
if you're interested in abstinence of any type or experimenting with that,
my,
my recommendation would actually be if you really want to see very clear return
on investment quickly,
uh,
I would just Google 21 day,
no complaint,
experiment and look for a blog post that I wrote about a 21 day,
experiment.
And this translates very quickly to multiple domains when you remove certain
patterns of freezing.
And not only speaking with therefore thinking,
uh,
the way that you relate to the world and the selection bias you use for seeing
the good or seeing the bad changes very dramatically.
So I would recommend taking a look at that as well.
And that they can be very much right.
Yeah,
no problem.
APPS,
if you have,
my dog is whining so I have to take Molly out to pee.
Uh,
but if you want to get me,
if you want to give me a quick question,
she's looking straight into gazing into my eyes as I record this.
I have to get here,
I have to get her outside.
But what is,
if you have one more question that I can potentially answer quickly,
I'm happy to take a stab at it.
I have a quick bite and I say it's a quick question but another,
another thing in my mind was I know that you are experimenting a lot with take
an LX and in how they can,
they can be used to treat certain elements or,
or you know,
for healing.
And I'm just curious as a person,
you know,
I went,
I went to college for anthropology and I work right now with individuals
optimizing their performance through different tools.
Um,
and I'm thinking when is it a good time too to encourage somebody to tap into
that and,
and,
and how can you guide them safely if,
if you don't have a personal experience of it?
Well,
I can't recommend that you use psychedelics.
You live in the states and currently the classical psychedelics are under
schedule one,
which is in the same class as heroin.
So if we're considering side effects,
you also have to consider the legal ramifications and potential side effects.
What I,
what I can suggest is that you investigate something called holotropic
breathwork,
h o l o t r,
a PSA,
right?
So there are,
psychedelics are one tool in the toolkit for creating an,
a non ordinary state of consciousness that can provide insights and realizations
and also reprogramming that can be applied to different domains,
uh,
really across the entire spectrum of human experience.
But it's not the only tool.
It just,
it just happens to be a very powerful tool.
If you want to strap yourself or strap or encourage someone to strap themselves
to the front of the icebreaker,
but they're not without risks.
They are exceptionally powerful and can be used irresponsibly.
And uh,
that is why I'm lobbying very strongly to a shepherd.
These compounds specifically MTMA and siliciden through phase three trials,
along with a handful of other people who were working very,
very tirelessly on this so that they can be administered with medical
supervision and trained therapists.
Uh,
I don't think that this is that far away.
if the stars align in,
in certain sense,
and if anybody wants to join me in supporting that,
they should check out a few organisations.
You,
sona,
Uso,
Mna for Psilocybin,
which is where I'm spending a lot of my own capital and attention maps,
maps.org for MDA,
which is effectively there from a funding perspective for phase three trials.
Uh,
and then if they want to really come to bat,
I'm actually,
I haven't talked about this publicly,
but I'm going to be,
I am committing $1 million of my own capital,
uh,
to this over the next several years.
And we'll be really directing a lot of my attention at this field because I
cannot recommend at this point that anyone pursue psychedelics with the legal
ramifications that exist.
And also the difficulty in finding responsible,
trained ethical,
uh,
therapists who can support this work.
It's just the,
the bend,
the risk benefit ratio is really unappealing for most folks.
But what I was going to say is if anybody wants to come to the table and
believes as I do based on both the data and experience that they have,
the potential to change and even save lives,
saying treatment resistant depression and other conditions that then people can
go to Tim.
Dot.
Blog forward slash science.
Uh,
you know,
if,
if you really have some capital that you'd like to bring to bear on this.
Um,
so I'll say that,
but at this point I would,
I would explore other tools for helping shepherd people through the front.
Right.
That was totally,
sorry to interrupt,
but I was what I was looking for his word to go for,
to,
to support this research because I don't just want to fall into the hands of
whatever,
whoever,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like you just said,
it's hard to find responsible guidance.
Yup.
If you are an IDN in the yeah.
In the now,
but I know that potential for healing and I totally get it,
um,
that he's a work in progress and I totally support it and yeah,
you're right.
The holotropic breathing is great.
It just taps into something,
but you don't will be,
I haven't been able to fully,
fully,
um,
get the same result and maybe some matter of just time and continues
practice.
Yeah.
It's okay.
You keep practicing and uh,
you know,
also don't forget the slow and steady reliable methods at your disposal,
which would include,
for instance,
meditation.
Sam Harris has a fantastic new APP which will be coming out shortly.
The,
the waking up APP.
I would encourage people to take a look at that.
There are other options like Coleman headspace,
but when you start to layer these things on top of one another,
you also very often see effects that are disproportionate and not additive.
In other words,
you take meditation one unit,
Holotropic Breathwork,
one unit and then say hot and cold work,
say sauna and ice bath one unit,
and you add those up and it's instead of being three,
you get a five or six or seven.
So,
uh,
I would encourage you to responsibly experiments.
Uh,
all right,
Diane,
I got to run because I have a list of 20 people to call that I'm going to try to
get through.
Oh,
go ahead
so much.
I hope we can set a tempo and connect again and it was amazing to shatter these
time and space with you and thank you so much for doing this and everything
you're putting out there.
It's amazing.
No problem.
My pleasure.
And I'll still uProxy man,
thanks for taking the time broke.
Broke.
Okay,
bye.
Bye.
This is Robin.
Hey Robin,
this is Tim Ferriss.
How are you?
Excellent.
I'm doing so well,
Tim,
how are you doing?
Oh,
splendid.
Couldn't be better.
And I am excited to be on the phone with you.
So how might I help?
We'll see.
I can fabricate an answer and an attempt to be helpful.
I can't promise they'll be of any value,
but what's,
uh,
what's on your mind?
What can I,
what can I potentially help with?
Yeah,
thank you.
Um,
a delight to be here.
I've admired for what,
10 years now your work and,
and your sharing your work with people like us who sort of follow along in that
same time.
I've built two somewhat successful businesses,
a cafe in San Francisco and an annual conference.
But the thing you've done so successfully that I really am just kind of in awe
of is continually hitting success after success in a way that appeals to the
same target audience.
Um,
so I,
I know you've talked about it not always being a successful,
uh,
four hour chef for example,
not doing quite as well if you'd wanted or even I remember what was it,
rust and iron?
The little,
yeah.
You sounded that you did about others or multiple TV or multiple TV shows that
I've attempted on cable and elsewhere
for sure.
Uh,
and yet you continually spring back.
So I look at four hour workweek through to this podcast.
This appeals to people like me.
I'm a,
you know,
white male living in the extended area actually just left same Cisco after 10
years,
um,
but still in the extended Barea and 31.
Um,
and you're able to create content that appeals to that same audience and then
seemingly grow that audience over time.
Um,
I understand starting niche,
but personally and,
and in terms of,
I guess professionally finding the next hit and then the next hit after that,
what do you think other than maybe luck has contributed to that sort of ongoing
growing success of teaching?
Essentially people like you.
Cool.
Uh,
this is a good,
this is a good topic to explore and hopefully my answer is an underwhelming.
I'll try to fuel it with some more Tequila to make it more interesting.
Uh,
let me,
uh,
let me ask a few clarifying questions.
If I could.
Uh,
first of all,
I mean you have a shot here,
she might as well mention it.
What is your cafe and what does the conference
thank you.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's by sounded it two years ago.
It's called Robin cafe,
that 17 gunshot shot wound in the mission in San Francisco.
Uh,
and then the conference is about how we work in the 21st century called
responsive contracts made and bounce back and forth every year between San
Francisco and New York.
It's responsive conference.com happening September 24th and 25th in New York
this next year.
There we go.
All right,
cool.
And what,
uh,
this is,
this is all going somewhere,
but how did you first come in to contact with me or any of the,
the,
the content that I've put together,
whether it be writing,
audio or otherwise?
How did,
how did you find your way to that?
Totally.
I think I would have come to it eventually regardless.
Um,
whether it's through four hour workweek or maybe when I came into contact with
your material originally has to get with time just after you had published a
four hour body.
Um,
but like I've come to know Jenny's our client is a dear friend,
the cofounder of Apple
Yoga.
Yeah,
she's great.
You've done a little bit.
Um,
Chris Fussell,
the coauthor of team of teams was one of my speakers.
So like I,
I've been peripheral to your work,
maybe very peripheral but sort of circling around for a lot of years.
I think the first thing of yours I saw that really hooked me was early on in the
Shopify competitions.
You had a little video about building online businesses and at the time I was
dabbling with Shopify,
uh,
trying to sell a digital content for parents of kids with autism,
which was a,
a career of about five years that I had there.
Uh,
and,
and something about your authenticity,
the,
a video that then led me to your first ted talk.
That then funnily enough led me four hour work week and I really been following
along some fat.
Very cool.
I appreciate the context.
All right,
so let me try to tackle this and uh,
I'll,
I'll edge into it a few different ways.
So the first,
the first thing I would say as a caveat is that even if I make a very overt
attempt to talk about my failures and missteps and so on,
the ratio of successes to failures that make their way onto the internet or my
podcast or into the books still presents a very skewed perception that I succeed
a disproportionate amount of the time.
Uh,
and
what that does not mean,
however,
that I am continually failing.
And then just highlighting the one or two successes.
What it means,
I think if I'm trying to look at it as an observer,
is that number one,
I increased the likelihood of success by doing one thing very reliably.
I'm not even gonna say,
well,
but one thing very reliably and that is try to support and create products or
chapters that scratch an itch I have.
So it's a very simplistic model.
It doesn't always work,
but I assume that if something really grabs my attention that it will grab the
attention of at least 10,000 other people on the planet who speak English and
uh,
that,
that you start really narrow.
And for me,
I stick with what I know and what I know is my daily experience of the things I
want,
the daily experience of the things that bother me.
The daily experience of things that are a huge pain in my ass is the simple path
I have found to be most reliable for reaching 10 million people.
Reaching 100 million people is starting with the thing that you fucking know the
best.
And that is daily experience of pain or desire for pleasure or problems or
solutions and sharing that and really not fucking yourself by overthinking it
and getting too sophisticated.
Really focus on what you know as an individual and identify the primary pain
points and if you can find solutions to those for yourself,
uh,
generally speaking,
that will really transcend any type of category that you fit neatly into and
will affect a lot of people.
That's been my experience.
So it's a very,
a can't believe how fucking along that was.
Oh my God.
So hopefully,
yeah,
hopefully that's helpful in some capacity.
But the reason that I've had the success I've had in say investing is because I,
I have set very strict roles,
which I sometimes violate to my detriment.
But for the most part I've stuck with very,
very simple rules for investing in things that fix a personal problem that I am
willing to pay money to fix.
Right?
And that excludes a lot of companies that have done spectacularly well that I
have missed.
And it doesn't matter because you,
it's not about how many you miss,
it's about how many you actually get.
Right.
And that's true for entrepreneurship as it is for investing.
And I've just tried very,
very hard not to outsmart myself.
And it makes me think of a quote from Charlie Munger who's the right hand
investing partner of Warren Buffet.
And it is something along the lines of,
you know,
it's incredible how far you can go by trying to not be consistently stupid.
So you're not trying to outsmart everyone,
you're just trying not to be consistently stupid.
And what I would put into the consistently stupid category is,
is really trying to project and hypothesize too much when it comes to
entrepreneurship or investing,
like focus on what's right in front of you and it can take you really far,
so apologize for how long that took.
But uh,
this is something that I feel very strongly about because the results are so
clear to me when people pay attention to it.
Uh,
so,
so there you have it.
Yeah.
Nice.
And he reminded of what I think it was Warren Buffet who told you,
uh,
at a shareholder meeting,
I was like,
if you have money to invest,
uh,
invested in the stock market can get back to work.
Yeah.
Invest in the s and p 500 and get back to where it was like the most
disappointing answer from a hero ever.
But in retrospect it made a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hey,
if this isn't your game,
yeah.
If this isn't your stock picking game,
then you shouldn't play.
So you get your face ripped off.
So it's like put your money in the s and p 500 and get back to work.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then psychographic.
Um,
so regardless of what a person looks like or sounds like or where they live,
uh,
the focus on specific problems that I as an individual have.
Um,
and,
and who do I want to help those people like me to come,
whether they look like near not,
uh,
doing that consistently in showing up again and again and getting back to work.
Yeah,
totally.
Let me ask,
let me add a few things also because I don't want this to seem too high concept
30,000 feet
and that is,
I avoid a lot of big failures by failing quickly with a lot of low cost tests.
And that means for instance,
Rustin iron you mentioned,
which is this it and who knows,
maybe it will be resurrected,
but it didn't get nearly the kind of attention that I would have hoped given how
excited I was about it.
Right.
So some of these don't work.
And the,
for those who don't know,
this was a very short video series.
I put up a few of them on Youtube,
so youtube.com forward slash timferriss which were uh,
tours of Jim's think.
So think cribs for gyms,
right?
Endlessly fascinating to me.
Turns out most of the world doesn't give a single shit about it.
Uh,
and I did a few of these and uh,
they were,
uh,
you know,
I filled them on actually one of them was just with an iPhone with Kelly Starr
ad and then a handful of others with Mark Bell and so on.
We're with much nicer cameras,
but those experiments cost a few hundred dollars a piece maybe a little bit
more.
And I decided for myself what the Max allowable cost was.
So how much am I willing to sink into this to arrive at a decision as to whether
to continue or not?
And he's like,
okay,
a few thousand bucks,
I'm willing to put that in.
And depending on where you are in your entrepreneurial journey,
that might be 80 bucks.
It might be $0 million.
It might be if you're,
if you have much more to play with in terms of capital,
it might be $1 million.
But in this case I was like,
you know what?
This isn't a revenue driver.
It's really just for fucking shits and giggles to see if people respond to it.
Well or not.
I'm going to put in a few thousand bucks over a period of two months and see
what happens.
And what happened was fucking crickets and I was like,
okay,
well we're not going to do any more of those in less.
I receive some type of information that directly and powerfully in some
meaningful way contradicts this like f plus grade that I just got this
experiment.
So,
so if you don't mind going into the specifics,
how do you determine like I just launched a tiny little podcast called Xander's
strong,
my last name being Zander,
and again it was crickets,
but like I know I could ask everyone I know to leave a review on iTunes for that
project,
right?
If you direct your audience again and again towards a couple of videos,
those videos that will explode.
If you wanted to get sponsorship,
I think you probably could.
So do you determine crickets and that your audience,
your psychographic was not interested in Rustin iron.
Yeah.
So there's,
all right.
So if we're looking at,
just to digress but not really digress into a related topic,
if you look at investment pitches from startups as a venture capitalist or angel
investor,
you will surprise,
surprise,
see the same graph and a lot of them,
wow,
it looks like a hockey stick up until the right.
Fantastic.
And the question that any investor should ask among others is what percentage of
this growth is represented through organic growth in what percentage of this
growth is represented through paid acquisition?
Because founders being incentivized as they are,
we'll very often go into the dark arts and uh,
take some of their preexisting funding or whatever money they might have a
through cashflow or other means and invest it in artificially boosting the
numbers.
Right.
And you can do this in an attempt to trick yourself as well.
And I think it's Richard [inaudible],
Richard Fineman,
who said,
physicist,
anyone who wants to read a fantastic book should read.
Surely I think surely you're joking.
Mr Fiman,
one of my favorites.
In any case,
he said,
uh,
you know,
rule number,
and I'm paraphrasing all of these,
but rule number one is you must not fool yourself and you're the easiest person
to fool.
So I really try to a focus on real metrics versus vanity metrics.
And I would put in vanity metrics.
Almost every fucking buzzword does your that you can imagine like engagement.
I think it just does not fucking matter for the most part.
I will look at the,
and I cannot say this applies to everyone.
I can tell you how I will evaluate these things.
Okay.
So I'll look at the,
I will look at the,
and it's partially to determine whether something is dead on arrival with no
hope of revival.
Or if I'm performing an experiment and it's 10% off,
and if I tweak that 10% it could explode,
which is sometimes the case.
So if we look at Rustin ironed specifically,
I'm not just looking at the view count,
I'm looking at the comments and this is a subjective,
not even going to say science art,
but it's a bit of a gestalt pattern matching type of process that I'll go
through where I will look for intensity of feedback.
So if I look at the 30 copies,
love it,
people who hate it,
right?
I will look at the 30 and I'll primarily look at the people who love it because
it doesn't matter how many people don't get it.
It matters how many people do get it,
right?
You can have 90% of the people in a given city hate your fucking business more
than anything on the planet,
but if 10 of San Francisco loves your cafe,
you are fucking set.
You know what I mean?
Like you are set,
it doesn't matter like you,
you are going to have a super mega home run on your hands.
It doesn't matter how many people don't get it.
It matters how many people do get it.
So I'll pay attention to the positive feedback and if the positive feedback is
along the lines of,
Oh my God,
this would be the best thing I've ever seen in my life.
I really loved a,
B and c,
but it'd be great to have this and this.
If I see that type of feedback over and over again,
I will test again if I,
and this is also related to my editing process for books,
when I edit books,
I will ask people,
which for instance,
and these are almost always friends of mine who are writers that I asked to do
this.
All the lawyers are very good at editing cause they can find sloppy thinking and
words that shouldn't be there,
uh,
or ambiguous wording and thinking.
I will ask them to identify the 10% they would absolutely keep if I had to cut
everything else and the 10% they would cut no matter what.
Or The 10% that would cut if they had to write.
And
if so it takes only one person to love something more than the other 90% for me
to keep it in the book.
But it takes more of a consensus for me to cut something.
Does that make sense?
If somebody absolutely loves something,
even if nobody else mentions it,
it stays in because my assumption is they're at least 10,000 more people who
care about that.
And I don't want to live in the comfortable middle ground,
which is the gray of,
I like this because that is where you die.
And,
uh,
if you make something you think everyone will like,
you're going to make something no one will love.
And I try very hard then to straddle that and not deliberately create things
that people will hate.
But in the process of selecting for things that people love,
the side effect will be that,
uh,
in this pendulum of public opinion,
you will have people who hate it almost by definition.
Uh,
so,
so that is how I would look at something like rust and iron.
And I didn't have a overwhelmingly strong response even from a minority.
Uh,
they,
they did not offer,
and this is an indicator of a liking something and feel like I invested,
I did not get a lot of quality constructive feedback.
In other words,
hey,
this car is fantastic,
it's a Ferrari,
but the front suspension is fucked if you fix that,
it would be a home run.
I didn't get that type of feedback and that's part of the reason why I shelved
it.
It's not dead forever,
but it might be a,
whereas in the podcast case,
and here's,
here's another layer that I would add to it,
it's not just what other people think.
In other words,
with the podcast,
I was willing to slog through some fucking awful first episodes and they were
all terrible,
but some of them were,
let's be honest,
I mean I've done 300 now.
Hopefully it's better,
but some of the,
some of the original episodes are really rough and I slogged through it.
Why?
Because I was developing additional skill sets,
the ability to ask more questions,
right?
I was developing additional skill sets,
the ability to let silence do the work,
the ability to ask follow up questions,
which default followup questions yield a lot of fruit such as how did that make
you feel?
What did you learn from that?
How have you implemented that later,
etc. As well as developing deeper relationships with people I knew as well as
people I didn't know as well,
acquaintances or even strangers,
if you want to have a really funny,
uh,
slash frustrating experience,
you can listen to my first ever podcast interview with a stranger or someone I'd
never spoken to before that point in time,
which is Ed Catmull,
the president of Pixar.
I was really,
really nervous and I went,
mm hmm.
Like a thousand fucking times.
That drove people nuts.
Anyway,
I was,
I was developing skills and relationships or deepen relationships that would
transcend that given project.
So I cared less about where I waited less weighed,
maybe waited,
weighed less.
The public opinion of those early episodes.
Does that make sense?
Uh,
because unlike say,
Rustin iron where I was producing new content but not really developing new
skills,
there was a value to the practice of the podcast in and of itself.
And that is true of a lot of what I do.
I really try to select whenever possible for what will help me to develop skills
and relationships that will Trin transcend that project in part because I can
really effectively ignore the early feedback and I don't ignore it,
but I,
I it is 10% of my consideration,
uh,
feedback to determine the success of the project.
Right.
And that's another litmus test perhaps,
or another set of criteria that I've used consistently to increase the odds of
each subsequent project success.
Uh,
but it's,
it's in some ways laughably simplistic and uh,
uh,
it's really hard to keep something simplistic.
It's intellectually difficult to keep something simplistic because you want to
demonstrate to yourself that you're so fucking smart.
You start to add additional criteria and use spreadsheets and all this stuff.
And it's not to say that that stuff isn't warranted,
but if you meet with a founder and you're like,
fuck,
this guy gives me the Heebie jeebies it doesn't matter how good your God Damn
spreadsheet is,
that you should listen to that very primitive intuition.
It's probably telling you something that over millions of years of evolution is
more sophisticated than whatever you put into excel that afternoon.
Right.
I,
I've tried to really,
really,
really revert to the simple and if you want to give it a nicer name,
the elegant then the sophisticated or complex,
which is not to say there isn't a place for the complex and the sophisticated.
If you're doing,
if you're a,
uh,
a growth stage or late stage private equity investor and you're thinking about
taking over a company and replacing the management and improving operational
efficiencies,
will you better really know your numbers.
But that's not the game that I play.
That is not my power zone.
And I will get a Nyli did if I try to compete against people who are good in
those spaces,
just not my sandbox.
Uh,
so for me,
I really try to target areas where I have a really,
really basic advantage and that is that I can stick to comply.
I can stick to simplicity rather and a real pared down set of criteria when
other people are tempted to go to complexity and succumb to complexity and I
don't have many advantages.
None of us I really want to go as far as to say none of us have that many
fucking advantages,
so figure out what is easy for you that is hard for a lot of your friends and
start there and then look at your personal pains,
look at your personal desires and use that as a starting point.
If you're trying to create content or products that you hope will ultimately
impact billions of people and guess what?
A lot of these products like dual lingo,
right?
I was in there first as a as as best I can recall their first round of financing
at the time because it was the first language learning software that made sense
to me.
That solved a lot of pain points for me personally as a language learning
student.
And now as best I know,
it is the most widely used free language learning software on the planet.
Right.
Hundred million plus users.
But it didn't start by thinking about what those hundred million people needed.
It started with asking myself,
does this or does this not scratch the itch,
solve the pain that I experienced myself.
So I hope that helps,
but that's,
that's partially how I think about this kind of thing.
Now I really appreciate your time and taking the time.
Yeah.
Hopefully that wasn't too drunk.
Uh,
cool.
Well good luck with everything and uh,
if I ever make my way back to the bay area,
I will check out your cafe.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is sponsored by Sotheby's and Sotheby's wine,
which offers a selection of the world's best wines for every pallet and
occasion.
Many of you know,
I do like my one,
I do love wine,
must be the Malbec from Argentina when I was down there and maybe it's a
Zinfandel from California,
but I like it all.
I like lots and lots of wine.
Sotheby's,
as many of you may know is a global auction where they auction off many,
many,
many different types of things.
They're also a retailer of fine wine with locations in New York,
London,
and Hong Kong.
The recently created an online store where you can buy wine directly.
You might think,
well that's for millionaires and billionaires.
I don't go to auction houses,
but the wines that they sell range from $14 per bottle all the way up to 25,000
let's say Sotheby's allows you to sort it by region,
great producer,
or you can search for a particular bottle or by your budget,
which is probably where I would go.
If you're gifting wine Sotheby's,
suggest champagne,
red Bordeaux,
burgundy or Californian wines,
and if you want my opinion,
I would say,
you know,
try and Zinfandel.
If you haven't tried to Zinfandel from California,
but in any case,
just one restriction at this time,
south of east can only ship to New York,
California,
DC,
New Hampshire,
and Idaho.
So I'll say that one more time.
Now.
Put it a different way.
If you are in or shipping to New York,
California,
DC,
New Hampshire or Idaho,
check it out because that's where the wine can currently be shipped.
So visit Sotheby's wine.com that's s o t h e B o y s Sotheby's wine.com and use
the Promo Code Tim Tim to get 10% off your first order.
Again,
that's Sotheby's wine.com and use Promo code for 10% off of y'all.
Check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike in the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as a dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now.
That caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes into your schedule and making it
to a studio with some type of commute,
etc.
New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand.
And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you,
but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like not Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes.
And I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the realtime leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect,
so it can fit in the living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not,
and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys the snares of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer,
and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o,
n e p e l o t o n one Peloton [inaudible] dot com and enter the code Tim all
caps Tim at checkout to receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike
purchase.
Now you might say ma accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category.
So this a hundred dollars off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else,
or are you just want to get a fantastic gift for someone,
check out Peloton peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories,
including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code.
Tim.